like are you practicing gratitude while
you're practicing manifestation because
the universe will reward a grateful
person all day what are your gratitudes
and do you say them every night or every
morning so I've been doing this thing I
was going to tell you today I've been
doing this thing for 21 days now where I
found like 15 affirmations that I
absolutely love and I say 15 of them
every morning um and then I say three
very specific ones at night and I have
been really like no matter what even if
the baby's kept me all night and I'm
exhausted or someone I love is going
through something that's like really
dark and crazy um or the world that we
live in which is insane at the moment um
and has been for you know the last like
three and a half years in so many
different ways um I start with gratitude
and I end with gratitude and I really
feel
like I really feel like it's just it's
just changed